mexico calls in the troops to seize
breakfast flakes pops and loops yeah
mexico forbids american cereals for kids
380 000 boxes of kellogg's cereal were
seized in mexico for violating laws that
ban cartoon mascots from marketing to
children completely disregarding the
medical expertise of tigers frogs and
bears
in response general mills has switched
to using mexican drug cartels they're
great
i knew yeah that sucked so vast batches
of corn flakes and special k were taken
during a warehouse raid north of mexico
city yeah they rated a place for corn
flakes and special k and not even the
fun special k cat
i get it
still part of her complete breakfast
but that has to be the most boring raid
ever sorry i'm not getting my head blown
off over a box of fiber one your
constipation just isn't worth it to me
but i guess it's easier than fighting
drugs right the mexican consumer
protection agency also took issue with
the lack of clear nutritional labeling
like calories and sugar content and also
some of the prizes were complete
of course no one wants to eat cereal
with an adult on the box right
all right
fella flakes for breakfast
and it comes with a free wardrobe
oh boy
this is the worst day of my life
i gotta get rid of the clothes somewhere
digging could you argue
that breakfast cereals do more damage
than drugs i would rather be high than
fat
um
what i ate sugary cereal my entire
childhood and i'm clearly fine
[Laughter]
i've got a head full of metal fillings
yeah and i have a huge addiction to
sugar yes plus i have had lifelong
nightmares about a vicious little
leprechaun humping marshmallows yes but
look at
look at jimmy he's fred flintstone over
here humping some fruity pebbles love it
yeah yeah all day yeah fruity pebbles
yeah flakes coco i love i i love
jimmy i love the cereal aisle and not
for the clientele
but the the
the just the entire array of selections
yeah it's mind-blowing it's incredible
is that like that could be the best
thing america does should we invade
mexico and get our cereal back that's an
excellent question greg and it's
appropriate that i talk about this since
i've gotten fat let's be really honest
you think i don't know my head looks
like one of john candy's testicles i
can't even look at myself in camera
but yeah you know the reason they turned
on me and this joke is really going to
bomb but i'm going to plow ahead
the reason that mexicans feel this way
is because when they arrested el chapo
he was in the honeycomb hideout boom
[Music]
there's a great jim norton classic joke
thank you yes
oh my god
is this the best priority for mexico
jimmy what's up
nobody laughed harder at the serial
factory raid than the guys in the
submarine sailing across our border with
2 000 pounds of fentanyl that's true but
how like demeaning is this the kellogg's
because this is a government that'll let
you swallow a balloon full of heroin and
leave the country but they won't let you
swallow kellogg's frosted flakes now i
get the whole idea though that 73 of the
children in the country are obese right
but i think they should embrace the
upside to that which is kidnappings are
down yeah you know what i mean well
they're heavy
you ain't getting these kids into the
car in time to elude the police not if
you're eating cookie chris you gotta
look at the upside yeah
i agree with the woman who played daisy
duke in the back up season with coy and
vance i think she makes a lot of good
points over here
says the guy who looks like the guy who
should be giving me directions to a
massage parlor best case scenario yes
but it is funny cat
like cooking crisp cereal is just a bowl
of cookies did you ever were you did you
ever eat an entire box of cereal i have
it's like unstoppable you you have a
favorite whether it's captain crunch or
anything i will i will sit down and if
i've got enough milk i will not stop i'm
like a horse with hay
i don't even know have you you don't do
that i know i feel like nobody wants to
hear my opinion on obesity
let alone like childhood obesity i don't
have kids or obesity or obese kids so i
feel like whatever i say people be like
that's so insensitive i'm like hey your
kid's overweight give him a little
nicotine gum
but i would never say that i hope that
somebody takes that out of context and
post that kills the appetite yes and
post that on some media websites i would
never ever say that yeah chase your
captain crunch with some robitussin
we are we are not a good place for help
for health tips
this segment peaked at the honeycomb
hideout no they did
i forget that that commercial is 40
years old but i love that as a boy
it did well i always wanted to go to the
honeycomb hideout it was basically a
fort and a tree yeah yeah it looked like
so much fun i know come to the honeycomb
hideout yeah
i would i would worry that maybe i
wouldn't be invited yeah that was the
thing like i wasn't cool enough for the
honeycomb hideout but it was kids always
were really cool they were were they hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else